big news this morning where to start
with this a caravan of Central American
migrants traveling for more than a month
is at the us-mexico border trying to
cross US officials are trying to keep
the group of nearly 200 people out they
want asylum that have not been allowed
to start the application process Customs
and Border Protection officials say the
San Diego port of entry is already full
president Trump vows to stop the caravan
which has become a flashpoint in the
immigration debate Matea VA al is just
across the border in Tijuana Mexico
Matea good morning well good morning the
US port of entry is about a hundred feet
right behind me over here between here
and there are rows of migrants they are
choosing to sleep on the cold hard floor
we're talking about families with young
children and mothers they have decided
to camp out here because they want to be
the first in line tomorrow morning when
the doors open so they can seek asylum
from the US they have been told that
this process can take several days and
there are no guarantees they will get in
a showdown at the border as the caravan
of Central Americans attempted across
into the United States Sunday some
climbed the border wall but didn't cross
over to draw attention to their ultimate
goal of asylum nearly 200 people lined
up to approach the port meline Charlotte
Prado is from Honduras and applying for
protection because of daily violence in
her country the truth is there's too
much violence there are daily killings
and violations of human rights at one
point the groups well to around 1,000
people as they made their way north from
Central America through Mexico to
Tijuana along the way they crammed onto
trains and buses with a few belongings
they could carry the caravan is now down
to around 200 people many traveling with
children watch the caravan watch how sad
and terrible it is president Trump has
warned they will not be allowed in the
u.s. I call them the dumbest immigration
laws anywhere on earth if a person puts
their foot over the line we have to take
them into our country lawyers are
telling them what to say immigration
lawyers deny they
coaching the migrants on the US side of
the border Sunday dozens gathered to
show their support for the refugees we
have I think a legal obligation to at
least hear these claims of asylum so the
way that he's used the caravan to stir
up anger hatred and racism in the
far-right it's it's concerning and it's
offensive several border pelagic
Border Patrol agents say that there were
people who actually crossed the border
illegally that were associated with the
caravan by climbing over a metal scrap
wall for the people though that are here
and are weighty we know that several of
them have been given white armbands to
wear these are the people that have met
with the immigration attorneys they feel
they have good cases for seeking asylum
and they are asking that those cases
take priority when the doors open later
this morning John
so Matt what exactly happens next for
those people who are waiting in line
well for the people that are waiting
right now they have to choose or show
that there is a credible fear of
returning to their home country they
have to show this and prove this to it
and Asylum agent also to an immigration
judge about three-quarters of the cases
that do that actually make it through
this process if they do some of them
will go to a detention facility they
could be possibly separated from their
families during that process others of
them are allowed to actually stay with
family in the United States they are
given ankle monitors so that they can
watch over them while they are in the
United States all of this is happening
while they wait to see an immigration
judge and that could take several months
before that actually happens very long
road ahead Medea video thanks so much in
tijuana thank you